in the heart of Brazil's rainforest
dozens of indigenous leaders meet to
form an alliance together they want to
stop government policies they say are
putting their livelihoods at risk
presidential poll senado wants to open
up the amazons reservations for
commercial mining and agriculture that's
of great concern to many tribes who see
it as a threat brazil's most respected
and revered indigenous leader chief
ronnie is leading the resistance against
the plants but he admits the issue has
caused rifts within tribal communities
there are relatives who support both
scenarios ideas so the president is
causing a division but those who support
him are making a mistake
we are against him and we will defend
ourselves deforestation rates have
nearly doubled in the Amazon since bosun
ro became president in January his
critics believe the fires that
devastated the Amazon last year were a
result at least in part of his policies
but speaking before the UN General
Assembly he downplayed the damage it's a
fallacy to say that the Amazon is the
heritage of humankind and a
misconception confirmed by scientists to
say that our Amazonian forests are the
lungs of the world based on these
fallacies certain countries instead of
helping embarked on media lies and
behaved in a disrespectful manner with a
colonialist spirit indigenous leaders
are now looking for more support at home
and abroad we have to come together only
through these alliances and movements
will we be able to bar this tragic
agenda that reflects both scenarios
government about 900,000 people make up
Brazil's native tribes the president has
promised to integrate them into a
modern-day economy but these indigenous
communities fear the price of doing so
could lead to irreparable damage to the
environment and their culture
katia lupus of the Y on al-jazeera